Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I know that I hung on the windy tree, wounded with a spear for nine long nights, dedicated to Odin, myself to myself, on that tree whose roots run from a place that no man knows. No bread did they give me, nor a drink from a horn down i peered i clutched the runes screaming i took them and then fell back again so tom holland that was odin i know the uh poetic edda so compiled in the 13th century but probably drawing on a longer tradition although that of course is is up for debate it's one of the best known things about Odin and the Norse myths and the world of the Vikings, the Allfather and his runes,
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我知道我曾悬挂在狂风吹拂的树上，被长矛刺穿，整整九夜，献祭给奥丁，以我之身献于我之身，在那棵树上，它的根系延伸至无人知晓的地方。他们没给我面包，也没给我号角里的酒，我向下窥视，我尖叫着抓住了卢恩符文，我拿到了它们，然后又坠落下去。所以，汤姆·霍兰德，那是奥丁。我知道，呃，《诗体埃达》是在13世纪编纂的，但可能借鉴了更古老的传统，尽管这一点当然还有待商榷。这是关于奥丁、北欧神话和维京世界最广为人知的事情之一，众神之父和他的卢恩符文，
the Raven God, all this sort of stuff. It's tremendously exciting material, isn't it? And Odin, of course, very much a friend of the show because he's featured in the episode we did on the Norse gods, but also he did tremendously well in our World Cup of Gods, didn't he? Well, he reached the final and I frankly thought... He was thrashed by Athena, it has to be said. I wanted Odin to win. I'm not going to deny that I wanted Odin to win and I feel slightly cheated. I mean, you know that the World Cup of Gods is a very sore spot with me, Tom.
渡鸦之神，诸如此类。这些素材非常令人兴奋，不是吗？当然，奥丁也是我们节目的老朋友，因为他在我们制作的北欧神话节目中出现过，而且他在我们的“众神世界杯”中表现也非常出色，对吧？嗯，他打进了决赛，我坦率地说，我以为……他被雅典娜打得落花流水，这是必须承认的。我希望奥丁赢。我不会否认我希望奥丁赢，我感到有点被欺骗了。我的意思是，你知道“众神世界杯”对我来说是一个非常痛心的话题，汤姆。
Yes, I do. Because of your shameful campaign against Anubis. However, let's move on from this. I do. But I think... So when we talked about Odin in the World Cup of Gods, we were talking about him very much as a kind of fan favourite, the star of Marvel comics and films. You are a foolish and petulant boy.
是的，我知道。因为你针对阿努比斯的无耻竞选活动。不过，让我们跳过这个话题吧。我知道。但我认为……所以当我们谈论“众神世界杯”中的奥丁时，我们更多地是在谈论他作为一个粉丝最爱，漫威漫画和电影中的明星。你是一个愚蠢而任性的男孩。
Yes. Sorry, that was my Anthony Hopkins. Very, very good. I mean, all that kind of stuff. But lurking over Odin and over the stuff that the Vikings believe, and indeed over the Vikings generally, is the nagging sense that it's all altogether weirder than perhaps we care to think. Because a lot of the weirdness, it turns out, is actually quite unsettling. There is one scholar who I think more than any other, who for me has articulated this, and it's
是的。抱歉，那是我的安东尼·霍普金斯模仿秀。非常好。我的意思是，所有这些东西。但是，潜伏在奥丁身上，潜伏在维京人所相信的事物上，甚至潜伏在维京人整体身上的是一种挥之不去的感官，即这一切比我们愿意想象的要怪异得多。因为事实证明，这种怪异中的很多部分实际上相当令人不安。有一位学者，我认为他比任何人都更能为我阐明这一点，那就是
Neil Price, who is British, but went to work as an archaeologist in Sweden. Very, very distinguished. He's a professor of archaeology now at Hübsler. He wrote an excellent book called Children of Ash and Elm, didn't he, that came out and I think was nominated by a leading historian who writes for the Sunday Times, perhaps not a million miles from where you're sitting now, as the history book of the year. Britain's top book critic, I think, is the technical description, Tom, as the Sunday Times history book of the year. So
尼尔·普莱斯，他是英国人，但后来去瑞典担任考古学家。非常、非常杰出。他现在是乌普萨拉大学的考古学教授。他写了一本非常棒的书叫《灰烬与榆树之子》（Children of Ash and Elm），不是吗？这本书出版后，我想是被一位为《星期日泰晤士报》撰稿的顶尖历史学家提名为年度历史书籍，也许离你现在坐的地方并不远。我想，技术上的描述是英国顶级书评人，汤姆，作为《星期日泰晤士报》的年度历史书籍。所以
there is no higher praise. No higher praise indeed. And I speak with experience of that. Neil was also the advisor on The Northman, that brilliant recent film about Icelandic epic. Yeah, you loved it, didn't you? Yeah. However, the book that Neil wrote that really had an impact on me was a book called The Viking Way, which had kind of legendary status among anyone who was interested in the period, because it was almost impossible to get hold of. And you'd kind of go on book groups and people would say, oh, I think there might be a copy in some obscure library buried in some distant land. And the whole thing came to take on the kind of connotations of a quest in Tolkien or something. Anyway, I finally tracked down a copy of this book.
没有比这更高的赞誉了。确实没有更高的赞誉了。我对此深有体会。尼尔也是那部关于冰岛史诗的精彩近作《北人》（The Northman）的顾问。是的，你很喜欢它，不是吗？是的。然而，尼尔写的真正对我产生影响的书是《维京之路》（The Viking Way），它在任何对那个时期感兴趣的人中都具有传奇地位，因为它几乎无法买到。你会去书友会，人们会说，哦，我想在某个遥远国度里某个不起眼的图书馆里可能有一本。整件事开始带有一种托尔金小说中那种探索任务的意味。总之，我终于找到了这本书的一本。
And basically, to sum it up, it's about how unbelievably weird the Vikings were. And when I read it, I immediately knew that I was onto something because I just want to read what Neil wrote. When he went from England to Sweden, he's sitting out looking at a forest. He wrote, I was disturbed by the fact that the ancestral stories of the North should seem so much more intelligible when looking out over those Swedish trees than they had done while sitting in my office in England. So that immediate sense that perhaps an academic study in England isn't necessarily the best place to come to terms with the Vikings and with Odin and all that stuff. But he then went on to write about the way that the models, the frameworks of explanation that academics have constructed around the Vikings. And he says, where do we find in these?
基本上，总结一下，它是关于维京人有多么不可思议的怪异。当我读到它时，我立刻就知道我发现了一些东西，因为我只想读尼尔写的内容。当他从英国去瑞典时，他坐在那里看着森林。他写道：“我感到不安，因为当我望着那些瑞典树木时，北方的祖先故事似乎比我在英国办公室里坐着时要清晰得多。”所以，那种即时的感觉是，也许在英国进行的学术研究并不一定是了解维京人、奥丁和所有这些东西的最佳场所。但他随后继续写到学者们围绕维京人构建的解释模型和框架。他说，我们在这些里面发现了什么？
Serious consideration of the torch carrying man who walked backwards around a funeral pyre, completely naked and with his fingers covering his anus. We've all done that, Tom. We've all, have we? The herd of six-legged reindeer depicted on a wall covering, the armed women who worked a loom made from human body parts. The elderly Sammy man who was buried in a Nordic woman's clothes. The men who could understand the howling of wolves. The women with raised swords who paced beneath trees of hanging bodies.
对那个背着火把、完全赤裸、手指捂着肛门绕着火葬柴堆倒着走的人的认真考量。我们都做过那种事，汤姆。我们都做过吗？墙上挂毯上描绘的六条腿驯鹿群，用人体部位制作织布机的武装女性。被埋在北欧女性衣服里的年长萨米人。能听懂狼嚎的男人。在悬挂尸体的树下踱步、举着剑的女性。
The men who had sex with a slave girl and then strangled her as a formal sign of respect for her dead master. The woman buried with silver toe rings and a bag full of narcotics. Now, Dominic, you've written a book about the Vikings. Have you put any of that in? Well, it's a children's book, Tom. Actually, do you know what? The Strangling of the Slave Girl is in that book. Right.
与女奴发生性关系然后将其勒死，作为对她死去的男主人表示正式尊重的男人。埋着银色脚趾环和一袋毒品的女人。现在，多米尼克，你写过一本关于维京人的书。你把这些写进去了吗？嗯，那是一本童书，汤姆。其实，你知道吗？勒死女奴的情节在那本书里。对。
Because I have the funeral. I have Ibn Fadlan, the great traveller, the great sort of Arabic travel writer, describing this funeral. I mean, I did tone it down for child readers, but I have to say Penguin did raise their eyebrows when I put that in. And as always, my son said, it's the best thing in the book. More of this stuff, please. And we had it in our episode on the Vikings going up in the East, didn't we? In the East.
因为我有那个葬礼。我有伟大的旅行家、伟大的阿拉伯游记作家伊本·法德兰对这场葬礼的描述。我的意思是，我确实为儿童读者淡化了它，但我必须说，当我把它放进去时，企鹅出版社确实挑了挑眉毛。而且一如既往，我儿子说，这是书里最好的部分。请多写点这种东西。我们在关于维京人向东方进发的节目里也提到了，不是吗？在东方。
Yeah, a lot of people, if you haven't listened to that episode, I mean, that's one of the strangest episodes we did, isn't it? Well, I think this episode is going to be stranger because we have with us none other than the great Neil Price himself. So Neil, thank you so much for joining us. Welcome to the rest is history. Thank you. Would you say that kind of Viking weird shit sums up what you've written about in the Viking way? Sadly, yes. I think in your introduction, you really captured what I felt, my motivation for working on all of that. And it's not so much things that I discovered that no one knew before. It's more things that we all knew about, but just had kind of collectively ignored. And when I did my first degree back in the 80s in London, the Vikings I learned about were very traditional people. And there was nothing wrong with that Viking age.
是的，很多人，如果你没听过那一集，我的意思是，那是我们做过的最奇怪的节目之一，不是吗？嗯，我认为这一集会更奇怪，因为我们请到了伟大的尼尔·普莱斯本人。所以尼尔，非常感谢你加入我们。欢迎来到《历史余温》。谢谢。你会说那种“维京怪事”总结了你在《维京之路》中写的内容吗？遗憾的是，是的。我想在你的介绍中，你真的捕捉到了我的感受，我研究所有这些内容的动机。这与其说是我发现了没人知道的东西，不如说是我们都知道，但只是集体忽略了的东西。当我在80年代在伦敦读第一个学位时，我了解到的维京人是非常传统的人。那个维京时代没什么不对。
It's just that there was something missing from it. And the more I read and the more I encountered all these weird things, I wanted to put them back into that picture. So that's really where it started. So do you think what happened to the Vikings? I mean, we don't want to sort of get into a massive historiographical discussion, but is what happened to them a combination of Christianity, Wagner, Marvel comics and so on, that basically sort of tamed them and took the strangeness out, if you like. Yeah, I think that's a good way to put it. I think also that their strangeness has kind of been weaponized and taken on new forms.
只是它缺少了一些东西。我读得越多，遇到的这些怪事越多，我就越想把它们放回那幅图景中。所以这确实是它开始的地方。那么你认为维京人发生了什么？我的意思是，我们不想陷入大规模的史学讨论，但发生在他们身上的事情是基督教、瓦格纳、漫威漫画等等的结合，基本上驯服了他们，去掉了他们的怪异感，如果你愿意这么说的话。是的，我认为这是一个很好的说法。我也认为他们的怪异感已经被武器化并采取了新的形式。
And the thing to remember about all of those legacies of the Vikings is that wherever they come from, whether it's sort of Victorian imperialism or the Nazis or whether it's reenactors or Marvel movies, a whole spectrum of different things, they say nothing whatsoever about life as actually lived in the Viking Age. And it's that life that I'd like to try and look at. But there's a challenge, isn't there, for an academic? A huge one, yeah. Who has to kind of, you know, be objective, use the cool measured language of scholarly prose to deal with people for whom that is not an aspiration at all, whose kind of visions and whose understanding of the
关于维京人的所有这些遗产，要记住的一点是，无论它们来自哪里，无论是维多利亚时代的帝国主义、纳粹，还是重演者或漫威电影，各种各样的东西，它们对维京时代实际的生活方式毫无说明。而我想要尝试观察的正是那种生活。但对于学者来说，这有一个挑战，不是吗？是的，一个巨大的挑战。必须保持客观，使用学术散文那种冷静、审慎的语言来处理那些根本不以此为志向的人，他们的愿景和他们对
world may be profoundly impossible to articulate in that way. I mean, do you think that's a kind of a fair summation of the problem perhaps that you face? Yes, I do. I think it's one that all academics face. And I was conscious when I wrote The Viking Way, it came out in 2002 originally, so it's 20 years old now. That sort of sentiment that you quoted about me being disturbed by the fact that those ancestral stories seem so much more intelligible when looking out over Swedish trees. There's a risk that that's a kind of romanticising view. There's me thinking, wow, I'm in touch with the Viking Age. And of course I'm not. So you have to guard against that as well. But I do think that whatever you're studying about the past, it really does help to go to the places that you're talking about, to see the landscapes, to, you know, to experience what a Scandinavian winter is like. When you look at,
世界的理解可能根本无法用那种方式表达。我的意思是，你认为这是否是对你所面临问题的公平总结？是的，我这么认为。我认为这是所有学者都面临的问题。我在写《维京之路》时很清醒，它最初出版于2002年，所以现在已经20年了。你引用的那种关于我因为那些祖先故事在望着瑞典树木时似乎更清晰而感到不安的情绪。这有一种浪漫化视角的风险。那是我在想，哇，我与维京时代有了联系。当然我没有。所以你也必须防范这一点。但我确实认为，无论你研究的是关于过去的什么，去你谈论的地方，看看风景，去体验斯堪的纳维亚的冬天是什么样子，真的很有帮助。当你看到，
say, reconstruction drawings, it's always summer, you know, they're never sort of hunkered down in a sort of snowed-in building, and yet that's a very large part of the year. So to sort of try and get that kind of experiential aspect of things i think is quite important but always to to keep your guard up around that kind of romanticization and it's that romanticizing that i think the vikings have been freighted with for centuries really so let's start at the very most basic sort of fundamental level neil um we're talking about scandinavia um so what what's now denmark norway and sweden in what sort of Sweden. Do you stick to the fairly traditional dates for the Viking Age, so roughly a couple of hundred years after the fall of the Roman Empire
比如说，重建图纸，总是夏天，你知道，他们从来没有蜷缩在那种被雪覆盖的建筑里，然而那是一年中很大的一部分。所以尝试获得那种体验性的东西，我认为非常重要，但始终要对那种浪漫化保持警惕。我认为维京人几个世纪以来一直被这种浪漫化所困扰。所以让我们从最基础的层面开始，尼尔，嗯，我们谈论的是斯堪的纳维亚，嗯，也就是现在的丹麦、挪威和瑞典。你坚持维京时代相当传统的日期吗，也就是罗马帝国灭亡后大约几百年
in the West through to 1066 or so, or do you think those dates are wrong? It's not so much that they're wrong. I think that I'd go for a broader time span and also one that's less specific. The traditional Viking age was always taken to begin with the raid on the monastery of Lindisfarne in Northumbria in 793 and then as you said end in 1066 with the Battle of Stanford Bridge. But I think that
到1066年左右，还是你认为这些日期是错误的？与其说是错误的。我认为我会选择一个更宽泛的时间跨度，而且也不那么具体。传统的维京时代总是被认为始于793年对诺森布里亚林迪斯法恩修道院的袭击，然后如你所说，在1066年以斯坦福桥战役结束。但我认为
apart from getting away from a kind of kings and battles history, looking at it in more social terms, I think the first half of the 8th century, so we're talking about the period 720 to 750, I think there's a lot of different trends in society, a lot of social processes all coming together kind of randomly to kick something off. And I think understanding what that something is
除了摆脱那种国王和战争的历史，从更社会的角度来看，我认为8世纪的上半叶，也就是我们谈论的720年到750年这段时期，我认为社会中有很多不同的趋势，很多社会进程都在随机地汇聚在一起，从而引发了一些事情。我认为理解那个“什么”是什么
that historians call the Viking Age, that's one of the big tasks we have ahead of us. And then broadly speaking, I'd say about the middle of the 11th century, sort of 1050s, 1060s. And just as there's no one start to the Viking Age, there's no single end to it either. Its motors wind down in different ways, different speeds in different places. So as long as we keep that broad vagueness in mind, I think that's where we are. But Neil, I mean, one of the things, obviously, probably the main cultural trend that happens in, it's happened by the 11th century, is that the Viking world is becoming Christian. And Christianity imports a particular understanding of humanity's relationship with the supernatural and the divine. And it's one that gives rise to what we call religion, this category that is separate
历史学家称之为维京时代，这是我们面前的一项重大任务。然后广义上讲，我会说大约在11世纪中期，也就是1050年代、1060年代。就像维京时代没有单一的开始一样，它也没有单一的结束。它的动力以不同的方式、不同的速度在不同的地方减弱。所以只要我们记住那种广泛的模糊性，我认为这就是我们所处的位置。但是尼尔，我的意思是，其中一件事，显然，可能发生在11世纪的主要文化趋势是维京世界正在变得基督教化。而基督教引入了一种对人类与超自然和神圣关系的特定理解。它产生了一种我们称之为“宗教”的东西，这个类别是与
from what we would call the secular. We can divide them in two. Whereas the sense I very much get from your book is that that would be a division that you wouldn't accept as something that the Vikings would have recognized, that they didn't have a kind of a division that you wouldn't accept as something that the Vikings would have recognised, that they didn't have a category of religion. The supernatural and what we would call the kind of the everyday world were absolutely interwoven. Would that be fair? Yes, absolutely, Tom. That was one of the things I reacted against when I was first writing that book or starting the research for it, was that so many syntheses of the Viking Age would have kind of chapter four religion. It was compartmentalised and packaged. And I think it's part of their perception of reality. Nothing more or less than that.
我们所说的世俗分开的。我们可以把它们一分为二。然而，我从你的书中得到的强烈感觉是，这是一种维京人不会认可的划分，他们没有一种……这是一种维京人不会认可的划分，他们没有“宗教”这个类别。超自然和我们所说的日常世界是完全交织在一起的。这样说公平吗？是的，绝对公平，汤姆。这是我最初写那本书或开始研究时所反对的事情之一，因为维京时代的许多综合研究都会有类似“第四章：宗教”的内容。它被划分和打包了。我认为这是他们对现实感知的一部分。不多也不少。
So even the concept of supernatural, I think that's wrong because it's all natural. It's just different kinds of nature. And asking, I mean, today we can ask people of any faith, do you believe in God? It's a meaningless question in the Viking Age. If you ask, do you believe in Odin? It'd be like saying, do you believe in a mountain? It's just part of the world. And I suppose trying to sum up the way I look at the Viking Age is to take as my starting point, it's a very difficult thing to do, but this idea of their view of the world. And I think that's what makes them different as well to the people around them. And it's something I think we've underestimated because most of the cultures on the European continent,
所以即使是“超自然”这个概念，我认为也是错误的，因为一切都是自然的。这只是不同种类的自然。而且问，我的意思是，今天我们可以问任何信仰的人，你相信上帝吗？在维京时代，这是一个毫无意义的问题。如果你问，你相信奥丁吗？那就像说，你相信山吗？它只是世界的一部分。我想尝试总结我看待维京时代的方式，就是以他们的世界观作为我的出发点，这是一件非常困难的事情。我认为这也是他们与周围人不同的地方。而且我认为我们低估了这一点，因为欧洲大陆上的大多数文化，
certainly to the south and west of the Vikings, not so much in the east, are Christian. And the way in which they approach everything, as you just said, Tom, it's an utterly different starting point to that of the Viking or Scandinavians. And I think recognising what their starting point might have been is the place we need to start. And that's what I've tried to do. Can I ask a very sort of basic question? So you talk about the starting point might have been is the place we need to start. And that's what I've tried to do. Can I ask a very sort of basic question? So you talk about the starting point. Let's imagine I have started out in the Viking Age. In other words, I'm a child. What do people tell me about the world and about, okay, I can't use the word the supernatural, but what we would now call the supernatural. So do people tell me stories of a pantheon of gods?
当然是在维京人的南部和西部，在东方则不然，都是基督教的。正如你刚才所说，汤姆，他们处理一切的方式，与维京人或斯堪的纳维亚人的出发点完全不同。我认为认识到他们的出发点可能是什么，是我们必须开始的地方。这就是我尝试做的事情。我可以问一个非常基础的问题吗？所以你谈到出发点可能是我们需要开始的地方。这就是我尝试做的事情。我可以问一个非常基础的问题吗？所以你谈到出发点。让我们想象一下，我出生在维京时代。换句话说，我是一个孩子。人们会告诉我关于世界和关于，好吧，我不能使用“超自然”这个词，但我们现在所说的超自然。所以人们会告诉我关于众神万神殿的故事吗？
Do they have a sense of, as it were, the Marvel Comics kind of view of Norse mythology is this idea that the inevitable progress towards Ragnarok and all that sort of narrative thrust. Am I told that as a child, or am I told the same thing as children in other parts of Scandinavia, or is it localized? You mentioned the word telling, and I think that is the absolute key, because they live inside a world of stories. And one of the things I bore my students with is to say repeatedly that the Norse, for want of a better word, didn't know that they had the Norse myths. That's something that we've created, that scholars have created. When you go in a bookshop now, you can buy loads of books on the Norse myths, but that's because they've been fossilised as a sort of effectively a kind of holy book for the Vikings,
他们有一种，怎么说呢，漫威漫画那种对北欧神话的看法吗？就是那种不可避免地走向诸神黄昏以及所有那种叙事推动力的想法。我小时候会被告知这些吗，还是我会被告知与其他斯堪的纳维亚地区的孩子一样的事情，或者是本地化的？你提到了“讲述”这个词，我认为这是绝对的关键，因为他们生活在一个故事的世界里。我让学生感到厌烦的一件事就是反复说，北欧人，为了缺乏更好的词，不知道他们有“北欧神话”。那是我们创造的，是学者们创造的。现在你去书店，你可以买到很多关于北欧神话的书，但那是因为它们被化石化了，实际上被当作维京人的某种圣书，
but which is not real at all. And at the time, I think that those stories were organic and they changed. You mentioned whether they were local or not. We don't know exactly what they told their children in this valley as opposed to the one over the other side of the mountains. But the sheer sort of variety and contradiction in the mythology that we have suggests that it was a very varied world. And in terms of what you tell your children, in the same way as you don't go in the forest because you might get eaten by a bear or you might meet an elf and you you want to be careful of them and that kind of advice for life i think is something that's baked into existence from childhood onwards and in terms of the gods i think they're a kind of a much more distant element of people's lives
但这根本不是真实的。在当时，我认为这些故事是有机的，它们会改变。你提到了它们是否是本地的。我们不知道他们在这个山谷里告诉孩子什么，与山那边的山谷有什么不同。但我们拥有的神话中那种纯粹的多样性和矛盾性表明，这是一个非常多样的世界。至于你告诉孩子什么，就像你不去森林是因为你可能会被熊吃掉，或者你可能会遇到精灵，你想要小心它们，那种生活建议，我认为是从童年开始就融入到生存中的。至于众神，我认为他们是人们生活中一个远得多的元素，
than we might think we tend to centralize the gods as a pantheon. You've mentioned them, there's Odin and Thor and Freya and people like Loki, the Marvel gods as well. I don't think anybody thought they were going to encounter Odin on a Saturday night, but I think that you might well meet those elves who lived in the stone behind your house and putting some butter out for them. And what would that mean to meet an elf? That's a good question. And this is one of the things that it's hard to be specific about. This might sound like a tangent, but it kind of answers your question. There is a remarkable sort of poetic list of the kings of central Sweden called the list of the
比我们想象的要远。我们倾向于将众神中心化为一个万神殿。你提到了他们，有奥丁、索尔、弗蕾亚和像洛基这样的人，还有漫威的神。我不认为有人会认为他们会在周六晚上遇到奥丁，但我认为你很可能会遇到那些住在你房子后面石头里的精灵，并为他们放一些黄油。遇到精灵意味着什么？这是一个好问题。这是很难具体说明的事情之一。这听起来可能像是一个题外话，但它在某种程度上回答了你的问题。有一份非常引人注目的瑞典中部国王的诗意名单，叫做《英林格家族史》（List of the Ynglings）。
Inglings. The Inglings is the name of their family. And it tells you what happens to each of the Inglings kings. And one of them falls into a vat of mead and drowns. And another one gets kicked in the head by his horse and so on. But the one I like best is led into a rock by a dwarf and never seen again. So that's what happens if you meet a dwarf or an elf. There's this idea of nature as a force in itself, something you have to encounter, something you have to negotiate with, keep on the right side of. And I think that idea of life as a conversation with a kind of invisible population is close to what we've later called Norse religion. And I think the gods are kind of the highest part of that. They're the most remote part of it. But if you're part of the highest levels of society,
英林格是他们家族的名字。它告诉你每个英林格国王发生了什么。其中一个掉进蜂蜜酒桶里淹死了。另一个被他的马踢中头部等等。但我最喜欢的一个是被一个矮人带进岩石里，再也没有出现过。所以这就是如果你遇到矮人或精灵会发生的事情。这是一种将自然视为一种自身力量的想法，一种你必须面对、必须与之协商、保持良好关系的东西。我认为那种将生活视为与某种隐形人群对话的想法，接近于我们后来所说的北欧宗教。我认为众神是其中的最高部分。他们是其中最遥远的部分。但如果你是社会最高层的一部分，
if you're a king or a jarl or something like that, then you're probably rather closer to that level of the other than the average farmer. Because there's a story, isn't there, of one of the kings of Norway who has got an English bishop with him and is supposedly converted to Christianity. And then this Gandalf-like figure with one eye and a brimmed hat turns up and lays on a kind of enormous feast in a big cauldron and everyone tucks in. And then the bishop in the morning, when he learns about it, has it thrown over. And obviously Odin has come to visit. So presumably for kings, there is a sense that Odin might come, and particularly on a battlefield, that Odin might be someone who is present watching what is happening. Yes, and one of the things that is attached to the Norse gods is that they're gods
如果你是国王或伯爵之类的，那么你可能比普通农民更接近那个“他者”的层面。因为有一个故事，不是吗，关于挪威的一位国王，他带着一位英国主教，据说是皈依了基督教。然后这个像甘道夫一样的人物，独眼、戴着宽边帽，出现了，并在一个大锅里摆了一场盛大的宴会，每个人都大快朵颐。然后主教在早上得知这件事后，把它扔掉了。显然奥丁来拜访了。所以大概对于国王来说，有一种奥丁可能会来的感觉，特别是在战场上，奥丁可能是一个在场观察正在发生什么的人。是的，附着在北欧众神身上的一件事是他们是某种东西的神。
of something. So Thor is the god of thunder, or Freyja as the goddess of love usually. And these things are not, I think they're a kind of misunderstanding because the Norse divinities are not necessarily gods of any one thing at all. So there are lots of war gods, for example, but they're gods of different aspects of war. And you mentioned Odin, He is very much the god of elites, but he's also the god of the homeless. He's the god of wanderers. He's the god of the mind. He's one of the gods of magic. He's certainly a war god. But most of all, he's the god of wisdom and a kind of elevated mental faculty, the thing that kings ought to have. And this idea of kings having a personal relationship with someone like that is very important. And some of the early Viking
所以索尔是雷神，或者弗蕾亚通常是爱神。我认为这些是一种误解，因为北欧神祇不一定非要是某一种东西的神。所以有很多战争之神，例如，但他们是战争不同方面的神。你提到了奥丁，他非常是精英之神，但他也是无家可归者之神。他是流浪者之神。他是思想之神。他是魔法之神之一。他当然是战争之神。但最重要的是，他是智慧之神和一种提升的精神能力之神，这是国王应该拥有的东西。这种国王与那样的人有个人关系的想法非常重要。一些早期的维京
monarchs, they claim descent from the gods. They try to build themselves in to those genealogies as well. The queen is descended from Odin, isn't she? So that's an ongoing thing. So just on Odin, Odin in the version that has passed down to generations of British children, is Zeus, basically, isn't he? But I get the sense from your books that Odin is a much stranger and more terrifying figure than Zeus. Is that fair? I think so. I think this idea of relating the Norse gods to classical divinities certainly has some truth to it. There are many aspects of Norse mythology that you could clearly see have something to do with Greek and Roman stories and so on. And there's this idea of the gods as basically a kind of large squabbling family who are not entirely trustworthy. And I think that lack of trust is something that particularly sort of coalesces around Odin.
君主，他们声称自己是众神的后裔。他们也试图把自己建立进那些家谱中。女王是奥丁的后裔，不是吗？所以这是一个持续的事情。那么关于奥丁，在传给几代英国孩子的版本中，奥丁基本上就是宙斯，不是吗？但我从你的书中感觉到，奥丁是一个比宙斯更奇怪、更可怕的人物。这公平吗？我想是的。我认为这种将北欧众神与古典神祇联系起来的想法当然有其道理。北欧神话中有许多方面你可以清楚地看到与希腊和罗马故事等有关。而且有一种将众神基本上视为一个吵吵闹闹的大型家庭的想法，他们并不完全值得信任。我认为那种缺乏信任是特别围绕奥丁而凝聚的。
He's a very contradictory figure. Like I said, he's the god of elites, but also the god of wanderers. He's a being in whom it's very unwise to place any real faith. He can support you and support you and support you and then stab you in the back or suddenly give victory to your enemies. But there's also a kind of odd fairness to him, I think, that there's still a kind of sort of basic justice behind what he does. There are consistent stories of, say, warriors, human warriors, who are enemies in life, expecting to meet in Valhalla as equals, and then they'll be sitting at the benches and drinking and so on. So there's this kind of cycle of completeness around Odin as well, looking for one thing to really
他是一个非常矛盾的人物。就像我说的，他是精英之神，但也是流浪者之神。他是一个非常不明智去寄予真正信仰的存在。他可以支持你、支持你、支持你，然后从背后捅你一刀，或者突然把胜利给你的敌人。但我也认为他有一种奇怪的公平性，即他所做的事情背后仍然有一种基本的正义。有关于，比如说，战士，人类战士，在生活中是敌人，期望在瓦尔哈拉作为平等的人相遇，然后他们会坐在长凳上喝酒等等的持续故事。所以奥丁周围也有这种完整性的循环，寻找真正的一件事来
characterize what Odin is about. It's knowledge and the fact that he will give anything at all for knowledge. So his eye. But also hanging on the tree, right? Exactly, yes. As you read at the beginning, he sacrifices himself to himself, which is a deeply weird thing to do. And in this sort of delirium, he has a vision. That's where the runes come from. He sees them in this vision and picks them up. But Neil, they're hanging on the tree. So I assumed, maybe because I've spent too much time talking to Tom, I had assumed that that was a later Christian formula that the Icelandic writers or bards or whatever had just picked up and imposed onto Odin. But do you think
刻画奥丁是什么。那是知识，以及他会为知识付出任何代价的事实。所以他的眼睛。但也悬挂在树上，对吧？完全正确，是的。正如你在开头读到的，他把自己献祭给自己，这做起来是一件非常怪异的事情。在这种谵妄中，他有了一个幻象。卢恩符文就是从那里来的。他在这个幻象中看到了它们并捡起了它们。但尼尔，他们悬挂在树上。所以我假设，也许是因为我花太多时间跟汤姆说话了，我曾假设那是一个后来的基督教公式，冰岛作家或吟游诗人什么的只是捡起来并强加给奥丁的。但你认为
people in the ninth century, let's say, that they're hanging on the tree, you know, that it was there then as an idea? I think it's hard to be sure, but the influence of Christianity on lots of different aspects of the Norse mythological stories is very clear. There is a kind of holy tree in the Norse sort of traditional tales, this Yggdrasil, it's this great ash tree that holds the universe together. And it's usually assumed that that's the tree that is being talked about in that poem. But the idea of Odin sacrificing himself could have merged with the idea of a man nailed to a cross. And he's pierced with a spear so you know also resonance is there but at the same time odin
9世纪的人，比如说，他们悬挂在树上，你知道，那作为一个想法当时就在那里吗？我认为很难确定，但基督教对北欧神话故事许多不同方面的影响非常明显。在北欧传统故事中有一种神圣的树，这个世界之树（Yggdrasil），它是支撑宇宙的巨大白蜡树。通常认为那首诗中谈论的就是那棵树。但奥丁牺牲自己的想法可能与一个人被钉在十字架上的想法融合了。而且他被长矛刺穿，所以你知道共鸣也在那里，但与此同时，奥丁
has a holy spear himself so there's there's this sort of blending of different stories and it's very very hard to pick them apart one of the things that bugs me most about this is and i used it as the title of my recent book because i was looking for a way to describe the Vikings that wasn't the Vikings. I called it the Children of Ash and Elm, because the first human couple, the first man, the first woman, were fashioned from trees, an ash tree and an elm tree. The Old Norse words are Asker and Embla. And then there's the fact that the first human couple have names beginning with A and E. And it's like, ah, and I don't know. Well, Neil, could we just focus in on an aspect that pretty clearly doesn't come from Christianity? Because as you point out in The Viking Way, the thing that's distinctive
自己也有一把神圣的长矛，所以有一种不同故事的融合，要将它们拆开非常非常困难。最困扰我的一件事是，我把它用作我最近那本书的标题，因为我正在寻找一种描述维京人的方式，而不是“维京人”。我称之为《灰烬与榆树之子》，因为第一对人类，第一个男人，第一个女人，是用树塑造的，一棵白蜡树和一棵榆树。古诺斯语单词是Asker和Embla。然后还有第一对人类的名字以A和E开头的事实。就像，啊，我不知道。好吧，尼尔，我们能专注于一个很明显不是来自基督教的方面吗？因为正如你在《维京之路》中指出的，维京世界独特的地方
about Scandinavia, the Viking world, is absolutely it has the Christian German world to the south and in England, of course. But in the north, we have in the kind of subpolar regions, the really frozen wastes of Scandinavia, we have people called Sami. And your thesis in the book is that they actually have quite an influence on the Vikings and perhaps the way that the Vikings conceptualized the world. And focusing in on Odin, you say about him and this idea that Odin is a god full of contradictions and paradoxes, that chief amongst his many powers is his role as the male war god, but simultaneously as master of the female sorcery of Seitha, which was supposedly shameful for men to perform. So Seitha, the role, the influence of people in the
绝对是它在南部有基督教的日耳曼世界，当然还有英国。但在北方，在所谓的极地地区，斯堪的纳维亚真正冰冻的荒原，我们有被称为萨米人的人。你在书中的论点是，他们实际上对维京人以及维京人概念化世界的方式有相当大的影响。专注于奥丁，你说到他以及奥丁是一个充满矛盾和悖论的神的想法，他众多力量中最主要的是他作为男性战争之神的角色，但同时又是女性巫术“赛德”（Seitha）的大师，这被认为对男人来说是可耻的。所以赛德，这个角色，远方人们的影响，奥丁作为一种融合了战争，但也融合了一种更女性化的巫术实践的神的感觉。那里发生了什么，你认为它有多重要？要回答关于萨米人的第一部分，我认为他们被视为午夜太阳之地的人民和北方边缘的人民，实际上即使是现在也是如此。但在维京时代，我们知道萨米人居住在斯堪的纳维亚半岛非常广阔的地区。我认为关于维京时代被遗漏的一件事是，在很大程度上，斯堪的纳维亚是一个支持两个截然不同人口的地方，诺斯人和萨米人并肩生活，几乎字面上并肩生活在相邻的定居点等等。两者之间的接触领域非常复杂，正如你可以想象的那样，在各种层面上运作，包括精神层面
far north, the sense of Odin as a god who blends warfare, but also a kind of more female practice of sorcery. What is going on there and how important is it, do you think? To take the first part with the Sami, I think they're perceived as the people of the land of the midnight sun and the people of a northern periphery, even now as well, actually. But in the Viking Age, we know that the Sami lived over an awful large part of the Scandinavian Peninsula. And I think one of the things that's been missed about the Viking Age is that to a large degree, Scandinavia is a place that supports two quite distinct populations, the Norse and the Sami living side by side, almost literally side by side in adjacent settlements and so on. And that arena of contacts between the two is very complicated and as you can imagine operates at all kinds of levels, including that of the spiritual
以及我们后来所说的宗教。其中一部分是萨米人的灵性，他们的信仰和实践在很大程度上是人类学家所称的“萨满教”环极地带的一部分，这种世界充满灵魂和特殊人的想法，萨满，萨米语中称他们为“noaiti”，特殊的人，他们的工作是与那个世界取得联系，并作为中介代表你与它交流。而且，你知道，做各种各样的事情，治愈疾病，确保你的驯鹿没问题，或者伤害你的敌人，你知道，摆脱你可怕的邻居或者任何你想要的东西。而且我认为，我并不是唯一一个这样认为的人，这有很长的研究传统
and what we later call religion. And part of that is that Sami spirituality, their beliefs and their practices is very much part of the kind of circumpolar belt of what anthropologists call shamanism, this idea of a world full of souls and special people, shamans, one of the Sami words for them is noaiti, special people whose job it is to get in touch with that world and act as an intermediary to communicate with it on your behalf. And, you know, to do all kinds of things, to cure illnesses, to make sure that your reindeer are okay, or to harm your enemies, you know, get rid of your horrible neighbours or whatever you want. And I think, and I'm not alone in this, it's quite a long tradition of research
在这里，这与这种被称为“赛德”的魔法实践有很多相似之处，我认为这是维京人与——为了缺乏更好的词——超自然关系的核心组成部分。当我早些时候说我认为众神在某些方面与普通人的生活相当遥远时，我认为魔法对他们来说是核心。即使你看看后来的中世纪资料，伟大的冰岛萨迦，它们也充满了魔法。几乎在每个故事中，都有某种魔法过程在进行，或者人们知道的比其他人多一点。你知道，它一直都在那里。而在这中心，我现在要以某种怪诞的方式混合我的隐喻，但这种网的中心
in here there's a lot of similarities in this with this sort of magical practice called say that which is I think the the central component of the Viking relationship with for want of a better word the supernatural and when I said earlier that I think the gods are in some ways quite distant from ordinary people's lives I think magic is central to them. And even if you look at the later medieval sources, the great Icelandic sagas, they're saturated with magic. Almost in every story, there's some kind of either magical process going on or people who know a bit more than other people. You know, it's there all the time. And at the centre of this, I'm going to mix my metaphors in some grotesque way now, but the centre of this sort of web
是奥丁。他是这种“赛德”魔法的最高大师。在中世纪资料中，它非常清楚地描述了这主要是女性的魔法。只有女性执行它才是恰当的。在这方面，正如在许多其他事情上一样，很明显女性对超自然有着特别强大的访问权。这是维京时代女性力量的核心角色之一，通往“他者”的门户和对这种访问的控制，这在奥丁的情况下有点令人惊讶，因为他是，你知道，国王之神，精英之神。他是主要的战争之神之一，正如你所说。而他在这里练习女性的魔法。那些矛盾，有巨大的偏见包袱
is Odin. He is the supreme master of this saver magic. And in the medieval sources, it's very clearly described that this is a magic primarily for women. It's only proper for women to perform it. And in that, as in many other things, it's clear that women have a peculiarly powerful access to the supernatural. It's one of the central roles of female power in the Viking Age, this gateway to the other and control of that access, which is a bit surprising in Odin's case, because he's, you know, the god of kings, the god of elites. He's one of the main war gods, as you said. And here he is practicing women's magic. And those kinds of contradictions, there's a lot of enormous packages of prejudices
附着在练习魔法的男人身上。他们基本上是维京时代男人不应该成为的一切，这通常被解释为懦弱或恐同之类的东西，但这同样可能是对界限的挑战。很难确定，是的，但奥丁清楚的是，这是一个对你漫长而复杂的问题的非常长的回答，但那确实是一个非常长的问题，不是吗？是的，确实是，但他与奥丁有关的事情是他体现了那些矛盾。是的。我有时确实会想，考虑到真正了解这一点有多难，我怀疑我们所看到的，即“这不奇怪吗，这不太合理”，
attaching to men who perform magic. They're sort of everything that a proper viking age man should not be that's often been interpreted in terms of um cowardice or homophobia and things like that but it may equally be a challenging of boundaries it's very hard to be sure yeah but what's clear with odin is that it's a very long answer to your long and complicated question but it was a very long question wasn't it yes it was but he's the thing with Odin is that he embodies those contradictions. Yeah. And I do wonder sometimes, bearing in mind how hard it is to really know about this, I wonder whether what we see as, isn't that strange that this doesn't quite make sense,
实际上只是呈现一种当时没人觉得奇怪的模糊性的方式。如果我与维京人的工作有任何单一的收获使命，那就是承认维京时代的复杂性，它的多样性。好吧，尼尔，我认为这为我们第二部分做了完美的铺垫，我非常想更仔细地看看这种巫术，这种魔法，这种“赛德”在维京世界中是如何运作的。所以我们现在休息一下。然后当我们回来时，我们将看看各种各样的事情，包括，我要给听众一个预告，可能，我认为是我读过的任何学术著作中最喜欢的句子之一。你说，正如我们将看到的，马及其生殖器在维京时代与巫术有关，奥丁的种马可以在这个背景下被看待。在汤姆·霍兰德内心，有一个14岁的男孩在挣扎着想要出来。正如我们将在第二部分看到的，各种各样的非凡怪事要挖掘出来。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
is actually just a way of presenting ambiguity that nobody found strange at the time. And if my kind of work with the Vikings has any kind of single takeaway mission, it's to acknowledge the complexity of the Viking Age, the diversity of it. Well, Neil, I think that sets us up perfectly for part two, where I would love to look a bit more closely at how this sorcery, this magic, this Seitha might have operated in the Viking world. So we'll take a break now. And then when we come back, we'll be looking at all kinds of things, including, and I'm going to give the listeners a teaser here, probably, I think one of my
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。旁观者在观看这种仪式性的入葬，然后走开，回家或去参加某种持续的葬礼仪式，或在随后的几个小时和几天里经过那个密封的土丘时，感觉如何？他们如何表达他们的知识，即在那个坟墓里，一个他们认识的女人正在慢慢窒息，在黑暗中死在她伴侣腐烂的尸体旁边，有一天同样的命运也可能是他们的？对我们来说，这似乎是不可想象的，然而对于维京时代至少一些人来说，这显然并非如此。为什么？这告诉了我们关于他们的什么？在这方面，我们可以多大程度上信任一千年后事后诸葛亮的判断？所以那是尼尔·普莱斯教授谈论维京女奴与她们死去的男主人一起入葬。汤姆，我们谈到了一个
favorite sentences in any work of scholarship I've ever read. And you say, as we shall see, horses and their genitals had associations with sorcery in the Viking Age, and Odin's stallion may be seen in this context. Inside Tom Holland, there is a 14-year-old boy struggling to get out. As we shall see in part two, all kinds of remarkable weird shit to tease out. See you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是我读过的所有学术著作中最喜欢的句子之一。你说，正如我们将要看到的，在维京时代，马及其生殖器与巫术有关，奥丁的种马也可以从这个角度来看待。汤姆·霍兰德内心住着一个急于挣脱束缚的14岁男孩。正如我们在第二部分将要看到的，还有各种各样离奇古怪的事情需要梳理。几分钟后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. How did onlookers feel watching this ritual entombment and then walking away, going home or to some continued funeral ceremony or passing the sealed mound
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。旁观者在观看这种仪式性的埋葬，然后走开、回家或参加后续的葬礼仪式，或者经过那座封闭的坟冢时，他们是什么感觉？
in the subsequent hours and days? How did they articulate their knowledge that inside that grave, a woman they articulate their knowledge that inside that grave a woman they knew was slowly suffocating, dying in the dark beside the rotting body of her partner, that one day the same fate might be theirs? To us this seems unthinkable, and yet to at least some of the people of the Viking Age it clearly was not. Why? What does this tell us about them? And in this, how far can we trust the judgment of a thousand years of hindsight? So that was Professor Neil Price talking about the entombment of Viking slave girls alongside their dead masters. And Tom, we talked about a
在随后的几个小时和几天里？他们如何表达他们所知道的事实：在那个坟墓里，一个他们认识的女人正在慢慢窒息，在伴侣腐烂的尸体旁死于黑暗中，而有一天同样的命运也可能降临到他们自己身上？对我们来说，这似乎是不可想象的，但对至少一些维京时代的人来说，这显然并非如此。为什么？这告诉了我们关于他们的什么信息？在这一点上，我们能在多大程度上相信一千年后的事后诸葛亮式的判断？以上是尼尔·普莱斯教授谈论维京女奴随主人一同被埋葬的事情。汤姆，我们谈到了一个
horrific Viking funeral in our episode on the Vikings in the East. And that's actually something that there's been a lot of correspondence about among our listeners, a lot of chat on our Discord channel for our Restless History Club members, because that image of the funeral and the sheer horror of it is something that really lingers in your mind. You can never forget it, can you? Yeah. I got Neil with us talking about Viking sorcery. That's why that passage where you talk, basically, it reads like you as a scholar are essentially throwing your hands up and saying, I cannot compute what it must have been like to live in that world. I mean, your understanding of Viking sorcery, of magic, of how they saw the
我们在关于东方维京人的那一集中提到的恐怖维京葬礼。事实上，我们的听众对此进行了大量的交流，在我们的“Restless History Club”会员Discord频道上也有很多讨论，因为那种葬礼的画面及其带来的纯粹恐惧感真的让人挥之不去。你永远无法忘记它，对吧？是的。我和尼尔一起讨论维京巫术。这就是为什么你谈论的那段话读起来就像你作为一名学者，本质上是在摊手说，我无法理解生活在那个世界里会是什么样子。我的意思是，你对维京巫术、魔法以及他们如何看待
world, has that enabled you to get a handle on, to answer questions that you ask in that? What is this telling us about how they saw the world? How would they have felt about knowing that a girl was starving to death next to the corpse of her owner? I'd like to think that after 30 years of studying the Vikings, I understand them better. There's a danger in that as well. And in writing the kind of passage like Dominic's just cited, and I still do this every now and then, I write sort of things that are slightly more fictionalised and almost like little stories.
世界的理解，是否让你能够掌握并回答你在其中提出的问题？这告诉了我们关于他们如何看待世界的什么信息？当他们知道一个女孩在主人的尸体旁饿死时，他们会有什么感觉？我愿意相信，在研究维京人30年后，我更了解他们了。但这其中也存在一种危险。在写像多米尼克刚才引用的那种段落时，我偶尔还是会这样做，我会写一些稍微虚构的、几乎像小故事一样的东西。
And I think it's important to try to approach that experiential view of the past. And in particular with regard to Ibn Fadlan, the Arab diplomat who described this funeral on the Volga, there have been so many earlier accounts that focus on the sex and violence as if it's something almost like some kind of spicy orgy. And it's not, it's horrific. And if anyone has the slightest tendency to see the Vikings in a heroic light, they need to read Ibn Fadlan carefully carefully because it's a powerful antidote to that. So that was part of what I wanted to get closer to it.
我认为尝试接近那种对过去的体验式视角是很重要的。特别是关于伊本·法德兰，那位描述了伏尔加河上这场葬礼的阿拉伯外交官，之前有太多的记述将重点放在了性和暴力上，就好像那是什么香艳的狂欢一样。事实并非如此，那是恐怖的。如果有人有丝毫倾向于以英雄的眼光看待维京人，他们需要仔细、仔细地阅读伊本·法德兰的记述，因为它是对此强有力的解毒剂。所以，这就是我想要更深入了解的一部分。
I think to answer your question, Tom, I'm reminded of a remark I really liked in a review of my recent book, which is not really positive or negative. It's a comment that first I thought was a bit superficial, and then I thought it was really deep. It's one of those. And it really made me think. It was the better we understand the Vikings, the more comfortable we are with how little we really know about them. Yeah. And that gave me comfort. And I think that's where we are. But that attempt to understand the difference of their view of the world, like in the kind of things that you just described,
我想回答你的问题，汤姆，我想到了一篇对我最近那本书的评论中我非常喜欢的一句话，它并不完全是正面或负面的。这是一个评论，起初我觉得有点肤浅，后来觉得它真的很深刻。就是那种评论。它真的让我思考。那就是：我们越了解维京人，我们就越能坦然面对我们对他们知之甚少的事实。是的。这让我感到安慰。我想这就是我们现在的处境。但是，那种试图理解他们世界观差异的尝试，就像你刚才描述的那种事情，
particularly funerary sacrifice, and not just of enslaved people, but of people's partners and even friends sometimes. It's so alien to us and it clearly wasn't to them. And it's that kind of extremity of experience that is part of what I think we need to look at in the Viking Age. At the same time, it's not exoticising it because I think most people just stayed on their farms and never went anywhere or did any harm to anybody. So you've got this tremendous richness in there.
特别是丧葬祭祀，不仅是奴隶，有时甚至是人们的伴侣，甚至是朋友。这对我们来说太陌生了，但对他们来说显然并非如此。正是这种极端的体验，我认为是我们研究维京时代时需要关注的一部分。同时，这并不是在将其异国情调化，因为我认为大多数人只是待在他们的农场里，从不去任何地方，也不伤害任何人。所以，你在这里拥有巨大的丰富性。
Would it be fair to say, based on something like that, the sacrifice of the girl in the Ibn Fadlan account, or the example that you gave there about the ritual entombment, would it be fair to say that the Vikings, in their view of the world and their view of the relationship between the sort of material and the spiritual are a crueler more violent people than a we are now i mean i don't mean to to sort of heap praise upon ourselves or b then we have given them credit for as it were than we than we commonly think in other words are they more are they are they more unsettling do you think i'd go with the last part i certainly think they more unsettling, do you think? I'd go with the last part. I certainly think they're unsettling. They unsettle me. I often say that the Vikings are supremely interesting, but that's not at all the same as being admirable.
基于类似的事情，比如伊本·法德兰记述中那个女孩的祭祀，或者你刚才提到的关于仪式性埋葬的例子，如果说维京人在他们的世界观以及物质与精神关系观上，比我们现在——我的意思不是要夸奖我们自己——或者比我们通常认为的要更残忍、更暴力，这样说公平吗？换句话说，你认为他们更让人不安吗？我会选择后半部分。我当然认为他们让人不安。他们让我感到不安。我常说维京人极其有趣，但这与令人钦佩完全是两码事。
Right. It's a good thing to bear in mind. As to whether they were crueler, it's not a comparison I'd make, really. Violence is a big part of the Viking stereotype, particularly with the raids. And I don't think we should minimise that. it's not a comparison I'd make really. Violence is a big part of the Viking stereotype, particularly with the raids. And I don't think we should minimise that. They really did do their level best to burn down half of Europe.
对。记住这一点很好。至于他们是否更残忍，这不是我会做的比较。暴力是维京人刻板印象的重要组成部分，尤其是那些突袭。我不认为我们应该淡化这一点。这不是我会做的比较。暴力是维京人刻板印象的重要组成部分，尤其是那些突袭。我不认为我们应该淡化这一点。他们确实竭尽全力烧毁了半个欧洲。
And the cliches of them, you know, chasing the English and frightening the clergy and so on, they're real. But that's only part of their world. And it's not as if the rest of the world was wonderfully peaceful, because it certainly wasn't. I think that the violent aspects of their religion are startling. And they were clearly startling to their contemporaries.
关于他们的陈词滥调，你知道，追赶英国人，恐吓神职人员等等，这些都是真实的。但这只是他们世界的一部分。并不是说世界其他地方就非常和平，因为事实显然并非如此。我认为他们宗教中的暴力方面是令人震惊的。而且这对他们同时代的人来说显然也是令人震惊的。
And not just to people, to their treatment of animals, the mass slaughter of horses and cattle and dogs and birds and things as part of their funerals and that's something we really see in the archaeology um is difficult for us to imagine and in some of the big boat burials the classic sort of viking ship graves um you find sort of 13 14 decapitated horses you know that the ground around those ships was sorry this isn't probably an episode for children is it but the ground around those ships would be crimson and they'd hang them from trees wouldn't they so at upsala your home university there was kind of great trees weren't they at least according to christian sources yes to uh to adam of bremen who was writing about 1070 there's there's a sacred grove at the temple precinct of Old Uppsala,
不仅是对人，还有他们对待动物的方式，在葬礼中大规模屠杀马、牛、狗和鸟类等，这是我们在考古学中真正看到的，对我们来说很难想象。在一些大型船葬中，那种经典的维京船墓，你会发现大约13、14匹被斩首的马，你知道，那些船周围的地面……抱歉，这可能不是给孩子听的一集，对吧？但那些船周围的地面会是深红色的，他们会把它们挂在树上，不是吗？所以在乌普萨拉，你的母校，那里有那种大树，不是吗？至少根据基督教的资料是这样。是的，对于大约1070年写作的布雷门的亚当来说，在老乌普萨拉的寺庙区域有一个神圣的树林，
where trees are full of hanging bodies. And there's one archaeological example that does seem to be something like that. It's up in the north of Sweden, where, if I remember correctly, there's five whole bears that seem to be hanging from this tree. Yeah, that's very odd, isn't it? I once alarmed some people. I was on a committee to design new museum displays for the National Museum here, and I suggested that they should stuff five bears and string genitals. I should say that I sent some notes about what I wanted to talk about, and I put horse penises, WTF? So WTF? What's going on
树上挂满了尸体。有一个考古学例子似乎就是那样的。它在瑞典北部，如果我没记错的话，有五只完整的熊似乎挂在那棵树上。是的，那很奇怪，不是吗？我曾经惊吓到一些人。我当时在一个委员会里，为这里的国家博物馆设计新的展览，我建议他们应该填充五只熊并挂上生殖器。我应该说，我发送了一些关于我想谈论的内容的笔记，我写了“马的阴茎，WTF？”所以WTF？发生了什么
with horse penises? This comes down to a poem that's recorded in a much later manuscript. So this is a medieval story. And its title translates to The Tale of Volsi. Volsi is a name. And what it's about really is a Christian king of Norway in the late Viking Age, who's heard some rumours that some of his more rural subjects are not as Christian as he'd like. So he disguises himself and with his men, he goes off on a sort of tour.
关于马的阴茎？这归结为一首记录在晚得多的手稿中的诗。所以这是一个中世纪的故事。它的标题翻译过来是《沃尔西的故事》（The Tale of Volsi）。沃尔西是一个名字。它讲的其实是维京时代晚期挪威的一位基督教国王，他听到了一些传言，说他的一些农村臣民并不像他希望的那样虔诚。于是他乔装打扮，带着他的人，去进行了一次巡游。
And at one point he comes to a farmhouse and is invited in as a guest because they don't know who he is. And he finds himself a participant in a ritual where the woman of the household who seems to be in charge fishes out from a box a preserved horse's penis that's been wrapped in in linen and preserved with herbs and things and uh so around the dinner table they they pass this object from one person to another as you do and uh and as each person takes the horse's penis and this is the thing called volse um the the penis itself um they speak a verse and the verse is is highly sexual and explicit it's kind of 101 things to do with a preserved horse's penis basically you can let your imaginations dwell on that and um and and the king is appropriately horrified because this isn't really what he has
有一次他来到一个农舍，因为他们不知道他是谁，所以被邀请进去做客。他发现自己参与了一个仪式，户主夫人似乎是负责人，她从盒子里拿出一根用亚麻布包裹并用草药等保存的马的阴茎，然后他们在餐桌旁把这个物体从一个人传给另一个人，就像你做的那样。当每个人接过马的阴茎——这就是被称为“沃尔西”（Volse）的东西——他们会念一首诗，这首诗非常色情和露骨。基本上就是“关于保存完好的马阴茎的101种用法”。你可以让你的想象力发挥一下。国王感到非常震惊，因为这并不是他
in mind with you know the new christianity and um and he interrupts the ritual and um seizes this object and throws it to the dog and what happens is you know hilarity ensues and the the the local people of the farmhouse are not very happy about this and the the the woman who's in charge she asks the men to lift her up to look over door lintels and door hinges. So she's being lifted up to look over the door. And this makes as much sense as it sounds. It's very hard to understand what's going on. But when she looks over the door, she seems to have a vision of some other place. And she's trying to retrieve the volse that the king has desecrated. That's so interesting because that is in Ibn Fadlan's account, isn't it? The slave girl looks over the door and she says,
心目中那种新的基督教信仰。他打断了仪式，抓起这个物体扔给了狗。结果，你知道，引发了哄堂大笑，农舍的当地人对此很不高兴。负责的那位妇女，她让男人们把她举起来，去查看门楣和门铰链。所以她被举起来查看门上方。这听起来很合理。很难理解发生了什么。但当她看向门上方时，她似乎看到了另一个地方的景象。她试图找回被国王亵渎的“沃尔西”。这太有趣了，因为这在伊本·法德兰的记述中也有，不是吗？那个奴隶女孩看向门上方，她说，
I see my master. Isn't that right? Yes. This is the thing that for a long time, Welsathata, the tale of Welsi, was dismissed as a kind of medieval burlesque of sort of racy goings on among the peasantry that had nothing to do with any kind of Viking Age reality. There have been other studies that actually really are taking it quite seriously as a preserved poem that has something to do with an actual Viking Age ritual. But the thing that really kind of charges that discussion is what you've just mentioned is that in ibn fadlan's account of this great ship burial that the one that's so horrific and so detailed on the volga in 922 and just to be to be clear you know we're talking an arab account of a burial in russia
“我看到了我的主人。”对吗？是的。长期以来，《沃尔西的故事》（Welsathata）被视为一种中世纪的滑稽剧，讲述的是农民之间那种下流的事情，与任何维京时代的现实无关。但也有其他研究实际上非常认真地将其视为一首保存下来的诗，它与真实的维京时代仪式有关。但真正让这个讨论变得激烈的是你刚才提到的，在伊本·法德兰关于那场宏大船葬的记述中，那场在922年的伏尔加河上发生、如此恐怖且详细的葬礼——为了清楚起见，我们谈论的是一份关于俄罗斯葬礼的阿拉伯记述，
a hundred years earlier than this totally independent account that comes out of norway describing the 11th century and he's actually written down much later so there's no relationship years earlier than this totally independent account that comes out of Norway describing the 11th century and he's actually written down much later so there's no relationship at all between these accounts and yet in Ibn Fadlan as he said he describes the enslaved woman being lifted up to look over a door which is a very specific thing to do and as she does so she has a vision of another world and I think that is really such a close link to Vilsa Thutter. And bearing in mind, Ibn Fadlan is an eyewitness account, and I think we can trust it.
比这早一百年，而这份完全独立的记述来自挪威，描述的是11世纪，而且他写下来的时候要晚得多，所以这些记述之间没有任何关系。然而在伊本·法德兰的记述中，正如他所说，他描述了那个被奴役的妇女被举起来看向门上方，这是一件非常具体的事情。当她这样做时，她看到了另一个世界的景象，我认为这与《沃尔西的故事》有着非常紧密的联系。考虑到伊本·法德兰的记述是目击者的记录，我认为我们可以相信它。
It really does imply that whatever it is they're doing with their preserved horse's penis might be real. Well, that sends a shiver down the spine. If ever you go to a dinner party, Tom, and somebody passes you one of those, you know what's coming. Well, it depends. I don't think I'd have the courage to throw it to a dog. Would you? I don't think so. But Neil, just sticking to, as it were, to horse penises, you associate it also with Sleipnir, who is the eight-legged horse that Odin rides. And that's quite shamanistic, isn't it? Going back to that idea of Seyðar, of this distinctive understanding of sorcery that you get from the far north.
这确实暗示了他们用保存完好的马阴茎所做的任何事情可能是真实的。嗯，这让人不寒而栗。汤姆，如果你去参加晚宴，有人递给你那样东西，你就知道会发生什么了。嗯，这取决于情况。我不认为我有勇气把它扔给狗。你有吗？我不这么认为。但尼尔，就马的阴茎而言，你也将它与斯莱普尼尔（Sleipnir）联系起来，那是奥丁骑的八足马。这相当萨满化，不是吗？回到那种“塞德”（Seyðar）的概念，即你从遥远的北方获得的这种独特的巫术理解。
Yeah, in two ways. There are so many kind of crossovers between the descriptions of these Seyðar rituals, and there's other kinds of magic as well, but Seyðar is the main one. Descriptions of that magic in a whole range of Icelandic saga sources and some poems as well, but say there is the main one. Descriptions of that magic in a whole range of Icelandic saga sources and some poems as well, that have clear links to what we know of circumpolar shamanism from much later periods. So if you bring all these sources together, you really can make a coherent case for this being part of a kind of, broadly speaking, a shamanic, circumpolar ritual world. And in particular, for example, animals that have more legs than they do in nature, like Sleipnir. This is Odin's eight-legged stallion. His name means the sliding one. He can
是的，从两个方面来看。在各种冰岛萨迦来源和一些诗歌中，对这些“塞德”仪式的描述，以及其他类型的魔法，有很多交叉点，但“塞德”是主要的。对那种魔法的描述在各种冰岛萨迦来源和一些诗歌中都有，它们与我们从晚得多的时期所知的环极地萨满教有着明显的联系。所以如果你把所有这些来源放在一起，你确实可以得出一个连贯的结论，即这是某种广义上的萨满教、环极地仪式世界的一部分。特别是，例如，那些在自然界中腿比正常多的动物，比如斯莱普尼尔。这是奥丁的八足种马。他的名字意思是“滑行者”。他可以
slip between the worlds. He has runes etched on his teeth. So that's one of the links there. But also this idea of sexuality as one of the big constants of, say, the magic. And it may also be that part of the rituals themselves are sexual in nature. So there is the sort of multiple layers of meaning in this magic. And we know that there are sexual, shall we say,
在世界之间穿梭。他的牙齿上刻着卢恩字母。所以这是其中的联系之一。但还有这种将性视为“塞德”魔法的一大常数的观点。而且仪式本身的一部分也可能是性本质的。所以这种魔法中存在多层含义。我们知道其中有性方面的，我们可以说是，限制和禁忌，例如，它只能由女性正确地执行。而且魔法本身的一些性方面和魔法的目的可能与此有关。所以，除了这种广义上的战争魔法或萨满教以及所有这些在人们生活中的重要性之外，仪式世界中性的一面也是我认为被长期忽视的东西，现在很多人正在研究它。尼尔，女武神是性符号吗？还是她们纯粹是战争符号？我认为绝对不是。我认为，正如维京人的许多其他方面一样，要获得任何类似于维京时代现实的东西——正如你所知，这是一件非常困难的事情——我们必须剥开一层又一层后来的
restrictions, taboos built into it, like, for example, that it can only be properly performed by women. And it may be that some of the sexual aspects of the magic itself and the purposes of the magic are linked to that. So along with this idea of war magic broadly speaking or shamanism and and the importance of all of this in people's lives the the aspect of of sexuality in that ritual world is also something that i think was ignored for a very long time and it's something that a lot of people are working on now are the um are the valkyries sexual figures neil do think? Or are they purely war figures? I think absolutely not. I think also, as with so much else to do with the Vikings, to get at anything resembling a kind of Viking Age reality, which, as you know, is a very difficult thing to do, we have to unpeel layers and layers of later kind of
故事和附加物。这种将女武神视为奥丁的美丽侍女，将战士从战场上扫向瓦尔哈拉某种永恒派对的想法，很大程度上始于中世纪，然后不断积累。然后显然它的终极体现是瓦格纳。这就是我们现在对女武神的看法，真的。是的。
stories and accretions. And this idea of the Valkyries as kind of beautiful handmaidens of Odin who sort of sweep warriors off the battlefield to some kind of eternal party in Valhalla is very much something that begins in the Middle Ages and then builds and builds. And then obviously the sort of ultimate manifestation of it is Vagner. That's where we get our view of the Valkyries now, really. Yeah.
如果你试图回到一种原始的女武神，姑且这么称呼，这非常困难。如果你看看女武神的名字。哦，是的。那么给我们讲讲你最喜欢的一些女武神名字吧。嗯，我找到了52个。可能还有更多。很明显还有很多其他的，只是那些在来源中没有被命名的普通女武神。但女武神有很多。
If you try and go back to a kind of primal Valkyrie, for want of a better term, and that's very hard to do. If you look at things like the Valkyrie names. Oh, yes. So give us some of your favourite Valkyrie names. Well, I found 52 of them. There may be more. And it's clear that there are lots of others, just sort of general Valkyries that don't happen to get named in the source. But there's a lot of Valkyries.
她们的名字绝大多数是对战斗和战争方面的生动描述，这并不奇怪，因为她们的名字意思是“挑选阵亡者的人”。她们的目的是干预战场，将最优秀战士的灵魂带到奥丁的大厅。所以你列出所有这些名字，你会得到：头盔碰撞、剑鸣、战斗编织者、嚎叫、链条刺客、议会痕迹、盾牌刮擦者、混乱、非常暴力、非常残忍、胜利催促者和磨牙者。我的意思是，这只是触及了表面，但“盾牌刮擦者”是我最喜欢的名字之一。但我的意思是，如果听众中有谁有女儿，他们需要一个……“非常残忍”是一个很棒的名字，是的，我知道。
And their names are overwhelmingly graphic descriptions of aspects of battle and war, which is not surprising because their name means choosers of the slain. Their purpose is to intervene on the battlefield and take the the spirits of of the best warriors to odin's hall so you list all these names and you've got helmet clatter sword noise battle weaver howling chain pricker uh council trace shield scraper disorder very violent very cruel victory urger and teeth grinder i mean that just scratching the surface there but shield scraper is one of my favorites but i mean if any listeners out there you know they've got daughters and they they need a hey very cruel is a great name yeah i know
还有很多人的名字意味着噪音，战斗的不同方面。它确实让你感觉到中世纪战场是一个多么混乱、嘈杂的地方。我并不把那些早期的女武神看作是奥丁的侍女，她们会造访战场。我认为她们是被释放到战场上的，我认为她们更像是屠杀的恶魔，而不是其他任何东西。几乎没有什么证据表明她们在身体上很有吸引力，或者符合任何后来的刻板印象。基本上，她们是可怕的。你也引用了这首可怕的诗。
there's also a lot of them whose name means noise different aspects of noise it really gives you the idea of what a chaotic, loud place a medieval battlefield was. And I see those early Valkyries not so much as sort of handmaidens of Odin who kind of visit the battlefield. I think they're unleashed on it, and I think they're more like demons of carnage than anything else. There's very little to suggest that they're physically attractive or any of those later stereotypes. They're terrifying, basically. You quote also from this terrifying poem.
《长矛之网》。《长矛之网》。所以男人的头颅被用作织布机的重物，男人的肠子被用作经线和纬线。我的意思是，这太……我的意思是，这是你能想象到的最令人不安的诗之一。这种将战斗视为由肠子编织而成的挂毯的想法。它附在一本著名的萨迦后面，但它可能比萨迦本身古老得多。它描述了一群后来被称为女武神的女性，她们在一台完全由人体部位构成的织布机上编织，正如你所说。她们创造的织物是由血肉构成的。
The web of spears. The web of spears. So men's heads served as loom weights, intestines from men as weft and warp. I mean, it's such a, I mean, one of the most unsettling poems that you could ever imagine. This idea of a battle as a tapestry woven out of intestines. It's appended to a famous saga, but it's probably much older than the saga itself. And it describes a group of women who are later described as Valkyries, who are weaving on a loom completely constructed of human body parts, as you say. And the fabric that they're creating is built of blood and flesh.
而且有一个非常清晰的想法，即当她们编织时，她们正在编织一场同时在远处发生的战斗的结果。你会感觉到，当她们移动织布工具进出织物时，这就是箭的飞行和人们投掷长矛的过程。她们实际上是在制造战斗。这是另一件与女武神相关的事情。这与诺恩三女神（Norns），这三位命运女神，有一种交叉。这种想法是，女武神不仅处理战斗的后果，她们也可能塑造战斗。大概，我的意思是，如果“塞德”正在进行，那么它的吸引力的一部分就是你可以调用这种魔法来影响战斗的进程，并使敌人的武器变钝，或者让他冻结等等。
And there's this very clear idea that as they're weaving, they are weaving the outcome of a distant battle taking place at the same time. And you get this sense of when they're moving the the weaving tools that are in and out of the fabric, this is the flight of arrows and the people throwing spears. They're actually making the battle. And this is another thing that attaches to the Valkyries. It's a kind of crossover with the Norns, these three women of fate. This idea that the Valkyries not only kind of deal with the aftermath of battle, they might shape it as well. Presumably, I mean, that's part of the appeal of Seyther, if it's going on, is that you can invoke this magic to influence the course of battle and to kind of blunt the weapon of your enemy or make him freeze or something like that.
是的，我认为这也是，我们之前谈到奥丁在这一魔法网络中有多重要。他与战争有关的品质与思想有关。如果你想到中世纪战场的所有混乱，就像女武神的名字、噪音和暴力等等，诗歌中一直强调在战斗中保持清醒的头脑。你真的需要知道谁在你面前，谁在你身边，那是谁，而且他们不穿制服，你知道。这种精神清晰度或一种致命的精神迷雾，这就是奥丁带到战场上的东西。所以其中一个女武神的名字意味着“战争束缚者”，就像链条一样。
Yeah, I think it's also, we talked earlier about how important Odin is in this sort of web of magic. Part of his qualities to do with war are concerned with the mind. If you think about all this chaos of a medieval battlefield, as in the names of the Valkyries, the noise and the violence and so on, there's a constant emphasis in poetry of being clear-headed in battle. You really need to know who's in front of you who's beside you who's that over there and they're not wearing uniforms you know um and this idea of mental clarity or a kind of mental fog which is lethal um that is the kind of thing that odin brings to the battlefield so one of the valkyrie names means the war fetter um like the the chain and
在实践中，这意味着当你绝对不应该犹豫时，它会让你犹豫。它会让你绊倒或丢掉武器等等。我认为这就是一些战斗魔法真正采取的形式。那么，尼尔，这是否意味着那种常见的都市传说，即维京战士通过吞食蘑菇或喝酒等方式将自己变成狂战士，是不正确的？因为我的意思是，我一直觉得如果我在战斗中，我会想保持清醒的头脑。
what that means in practice is that's the thing that makes you hesitate when you absolutely shouldn't. It's the thing that makes you trip or drop your weapon or whatever. And that is the form that some of this battle magic really took, I think. So does that imply, Neil, that the common, as it were, urban myth that Viking warriors are turning themselves into berserkers by swallowing mushrooms or drinking or whatever that's incorrect because i mean it's always struck me that if i were in a battle i would want to be i'd really want to have my wits about me
所以你认为那种狂战士的刻板印象被夸大了吗？非常夸张，是的。即使在最耸人听闻的来源中，狂战士，以及一种被称为“狼皮战士”（Ulfhednar）的表亲。基本上，狂战士与熊有关，而“狼皮战士”与狼有关，但它们是一回事。他们总是少数，极少数。目前学术界有一个很大的争论，关于他们是否真的存在，或者他们是否是中世纪的一种文学母题，或者他们是否真实存在，但更多的是一种仪式表演，一种让自己兴奋起来的方式，
so so do you think that is that is overstated the sort of berserker um stereotype very much so yes even in the in the most sort of lurid sources, the berserkers, and there's a sort of cousins to them called Ulfhednar. Basically, berserkers are connected with bears and Ulfhednar are connected with wolves, but they're kind of the same thing. They're always in a minority, a tiny minority. There's a big debate in scholarship at the moment as to whether they were real at all, or whether they're a kind of literary motif from the Middle Ages, or alternatively whether they were real, but more a kind of a matter of ritual performance, a sort of way to psych yourself up
而不是有人真的在战斗中这样做。个人而言，我更倾向于他们确实存在，而且他们是——进行这种粗俗的比较很容易——基本上是维京特种部队。他们是精英士兵。早期来源中没有任何暗示表明他们服用蘑菇或任何致幻剂。而且还有很多其他方法可以让自己进入战斗狂热。所以我认为关于狂战士的结论还没有定论。在维京时代的艺术或图像中，有很多关于男性，有时是女性的描绘，他们似乎穿着动物皮或服装。实际上，在丹麦一个城镇港口的沉船中发现了一对口罩，它们是由毛毡制成的，刚好覆盖了不会被锁子甲覆盖的面部部分。它们看起来……很难说它们是什么动物，但它们绝对是动物。它们在我看来有点像公牛，但它们也可能是狗。天哪，我的意思是，想象一下你是一个僧侣。所有这些戴着面具的人都太可怕了。
rather than anybody actually doing this in battle. Personally, I'm more inclined to the idea that they really existed and that they are, it's easy to make these kind of crass comparisons, but a sort of Viking special forces, basically. They're elite soldiers. There is no suggestion whatsoever in early sources that they took mushrooms or any kind of hallucinogen. And there are plenty of other ways to sort of work yourself up
而且非常不同。嗯，非常不同。所以我只是不禁想知道，对于维京人来说，战斗本身的实际体验是否是一种仪式，在其中你体验到灵魂或神性。显然，战斗是击败敌人和窃取财富的一种方式。但你认为，这是否也是一种以非常强烈的形式与你原本无法体验的灵魂进行交流的方式？
into a fighting rage. So I think the jury's out on the berserkers. There are a lot of depictions in Viking Age art or Viking Age iconography of men and sometimes women who appear to be wearing animal skins or costumes. And there are a couple of masks that have been found as part of a shipwreck actually in a danish town harbor um which are made of felt and just cover the the portion of the face that wouldn't be covered by by chain mail for example and they they look it's hard to say what animals they are but they're definitely animals they look to me a bit like bulls but they could be dogs. God, I mean, imagine you're a monk. And all these guys with masks are terrifying.
我怀疑对他们中的一些人来说，答案可能是肯定的。我不认为这是维京时代每个人的普遍体验，即使是每个“真正的维京人”，你知道，一个真正的海盗维京人。但我们知道，例如，奥丁的战争崇拜有一种狂喜狂热的元素，姑且这么说。有一种愤怒和“出窍”的元素，这非常与奥丁相关。我认为这种存在“奥丁式战士”的想法可能是真实的，但同样，很难回到关于它的任何细节。当谈论这些事情时，我非常清醒地意识到这是一种猜测之上的猜测，但这就是我们所拥有的。那是你的工作。我的意思是，好吧，尼尔，你已经给出了，你已经给出了，你知道，
And very different. Well, very different. And so I'm just prompted to wonder whether for Vikings, the actual experience of battle itself is a kind of a ritual in which you experience spirits or the divine. Obviously, battle is a way of defeating your enemies and stealing their wealth. But is it also a way of having communion in a very intense form, perhaps, with spirits that you wouldn't otherwise have experience of, do you think?
精彩的论述。汤姆，在你结束之前，我可以问一个问题吗？是的，当然。抱歉。是的。问题是，这种心态，这种对待精神世界的态度持续了多久？因为显然斯堪的纳维亚被基督教化了，你举了例子，我的意思是，你说1050年代、1060年代是维京时代的终结，基督教和基督教化显然在那种年代划分中起到了巨大的作用。但据推测，这种思考自然的方式——我知道我们不应该使用“超自然”这个词——一定在所谓的斯堪的纳维亚王国名义上的基督教化之后，还持续了几代人。
I suspect that for some of them, the answer is probably yes. I don't think that's a general experience of everybody in the Viking Age, even every sort of proper Viking, you know, an actual sort of piratical Viking. But we know that, for example, the kind of war cult of Odin has an element of kind of ecstatic fury, for want of a better word. And there's an element of rage and being out of yourself um that very much attaches to odin and i think this idea of there being kind of odinic warriors is is probably real um but it's again it's very hard to get back to any kind of detail about it i'm very conscious when i talk about things like this it's's kind of speculation upon speculation, but that's what we've got. That's your job. I mean, well, Neil, you've given, you've given, you know,
是的，我想是的。如果你看看北欧灵性的经典上层建筑，众神，我认为他们消失得相当快。显然，人们试图引入一种基督教的上帝概念来取代北欧的上帝，尤其是显然只有一个上帝。但所有那些更日常的信仰方面，我们谈到的住在你房子后面的精灵，我认为它们存在了很长时间。你可以在后来的民间传说和民间习俗中追踪到它们。你也可以在法律中追踪到它们。我的意思是，中世纪基督教仍然对各种黑暗力量有着相当活跃的信仰。我的意思是，尼尔，阿尔弗雷德大帝，他是一位无可挑剔的基督徒，他的名字是以一个精灵命名的。所以精灵显然仍然是基督教英格兰以及斯堪的纳维亚社会结构的一部分，我想。
brilliant kind of tour de raison. Can I ask one question before you wrap up, Tom? Yeah, of course. Sorry. Yeah. The question is how long does this mindset, this attitude towards the spiritual world endure? Because obviously Scandinavia was Christianized, and you gave the example of the, I mean, you said the 1050s, 1060s is the end of the Viking Age, and Christianity and the Christianization obviously plays an enormous part in that kind of dating. But presumably, this way of thinking about the natural, and I know we're not meant to use the word the supernatural must have endured for generations after the sort of nominal christianization of what become the scandinavian
我发现法律条文在这方面非常有用，因为它们往往是相当枯燥的文件，你不会禁止人们做没人做的事情。如果法律规定你不能唤醒巨魔并询问它们事情，那么我认为他们确实会这样做。是的，所以，好的建议。但有很多很多这样的事情，你知道，你不能以各种方式进行魔法表演，这暗示着如果你做了，那可能会成功。我认为从我们之前谈到的“塞德”到中世纪巫术有一条非常清晰的路径。这种关于力量的另一个世界的想法，在中世纪改变的是，它被赋予了负面含义，
kingdoms yes i think i think it did if you look at the kind of classic superstructure of norse spirituality the gods i think they disappear rather fast um and there it's there's clearly an attempt to introduce a kind of christian concept of the divine that replaces the Norse one, especially obviously with one God. But all of those more everyday aspects of belief, the elves that live behind your house that we talked about, I think they stay for a very long time. You can trace them in later folklore and folk custom. You can trace them in laws as well. I mean, medieval Christianity still had quite a lively belief in dark powers of various kinds. I mean, Neil, Alfred the Great, who's impeccably Christian, is named after an elf. So elves are clearly still part of the fabric
这在基督教前时期并不一定有。太棒了。非常感谢，尼尔。谢谢。这是我们期待已久的事情。绝对是。非常、非常感激。一个如此奇怪而有趣的故事。绝对引人入胜的故事。
in Christian England as well as in scandinavia i would guess and i find law codes are very useful like that because they tend to be rather dry documents and you don't forbid people from doing something that nobody ever does and if there are laws that you mustn't wake up trolls and ask them things and and so i think they do that yeah so yeah good advice but um but lots of lots of things like that that you you know mustn't perform magic in various ways which which implies that that that might you know succeed if you if you did it and i think there's a a very clear path to be traced from say there and there's things we were talking about earlier to to medieval witchcraft this idea of a different world of powers what What changes in the Middle Ages is that this is given negative connotations,
我听说你要去婆罗洲了，对吗，过几天？是的，我是。那里没有维京人。所以祝你在婆罗洲玩得开心，非常感谢，也谢谢大家的收听，我们很快会回来带来更多内容，再见，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐界的帷幕，
which it doesn't necessarily have in the pre-Christian period. Brilliant. Well, thank you so much, Neil. Thank you. Something we've been looking forward to for ages. Definitely. Very, very grateful. Such a strange and interesting story. Absolutely fascinating story.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And I gather you're off to Borneo, is that right, in a couple of days? Yes, I am. No Vikings there. So have a wonderful time in borneo and many many thanks and thank you everyone for listening and we'll be back soon with more bye-bye bye-bye bye i'm marina hyde And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
我听说你过几天要去婆罗洲，是吗？是的，我要去。那里没有维京人。祝你在婆罗洲玩得愉快，非常感谢，也谢谢大家的收听，我们很快会回来带来更多内容，再见，再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。